Days of Thunder, better buckle up.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
Did you guys see the Days of Thunder movie?
It's a great question, Mike.
I'm not going to answer it.
No, this is one of my larger action movie blind spots.
I've never seen it.
I watched the trailer before playing.
It was everything that I expected it to be.
I'm really glad that Randy Quaid, How Would Be Their Name, is in the movie.
So yeah, it's on my list of things to watch.
We got a lot of good people in this movie.
We got Randy Quaid.
You obviously have Tom Cruise starring in it.
Robert Duvall.
Nicole Kidman.
Sure. John C.
Reilly. Okay.
I mean, like, you know, I could keep going, but that's pretty strong.
But most importantly... You could have stopped at Randy Quaid.
Yeah, no one's going to beat that.
But the most important part of Days of Thunder, which I did not know before watching the movie,
is that Days of Thunder is like the Top Gun team getting together and saying,
we're going to do what we did for planes.
We're going to do that for cars.
We're putting cars on the map.
Right. Well, do you think they put planes on the map?
Yeah. I don't think anyone really flew before...
They didn't know how safe it was.
At least that fast. Yeah.
Now that's just a commercial jet now.
That's what they fly like.
This might be crazy to say, I don't know, but I have never heard of Days of Thunder until
this week, the movie.
Is that like...
Is this like a crazy cultural blind spot?
I mean, I share it.
It made a lot of... Yeah, but have you heard of it?
It made a lot of money. I had heard of it, yeah.
But I also don't have that much interest in NASCAR, even though I have been to a NASCAR
race. That was when I was very young and didn't...
Yeah. It wasn't really a thing for me.
The funny thing is, once you know about the whole like Top Gun connection thing too,
though, where it's like same director and all that, it's like Tom Cruise is basically
just playing Maverick, but if he was a NASCAR driver, you know, it's like the guy has no
experience in NASCAR, just shows up to the track.
He's like, yeah, I'll ride your car, dude.
He pulls like the fastest lap ever.
I'll ride your car. He pulls like the fastest lap.
And then the guy, of course, whose car he rode is like pissed off at him.
He's like, yeah, go find your own car, buddy.
Like, this is my car. And they have like a, you know, a film's length worth of rivalry to unpack after that opening
scene. But like, then the rest of the movie is just like, yeah, Tom Cruise is fucking awesome at
NASCAR. It's like, I don't think that's how it works.
Like, I think everybody wishes that they were like the people in the stands watching.
He's got his license. Well, but yeah, but they're just like, they're just turning to the left.
You know, it's like, I could do that.
Get me down there. And it's like, I don't think it feels like that.
Like, I think what you get in the car, it's a little bit of a different story.
Yeah. Like if you've never like driven like this, I don't think it's like, yeah, I don't think
it's going to be like super analogous to like driving your car around the block.
It's like, I got to imagine it's a very different experience.
Right. And he has driven before, just not at the NASCAR level.
It's not like, it's like, it becomes a thing where it's like, he, he's obviously like done
some kind of racing at some level, but it's like, then he just starts winning.
And it's like, that's what you, I guess that's what you want out of a movie, but it's also
like not very realistic, but like the movie otherwise is going for like, we are going
to capture the excitement of NASCAR on film in a way that like, we, you know, again, like
what we did for Top Gun where it's like, this is going to be like reference quality, like
amazing sound design.
Like you're going to want to own the VHS so you can play it on your big CRT and impress
all your friends. It's like, they're doing all that, but then they're also like trivializing just how freaking
hard what these guys do on the track is.
I mean, I liked, I liked Talladega Nights and I think that that, that doesn't really, I
think that that, that's sort of like my days of thunder, you know?
Sure. I don't, I think he had driven before in that one though.
Yeah. He was the NASCAR, like he was already at the top, right?
He was at his apex mountain before the movie starts.
I did hear though, that in days of thunder, that Dale Earnhardt is not in it and it's
just kind of like, why?
Yeah. Well, praise hell, praise Dale man.
Is, is, is NASCAR in general, like is the term thunder there because the cars sound like
thunder as they roll past you?
Is that, is that the idea?
I believe so.
Okay. Cause it's like days of thunder.
Isn't just like called that for being a pretty, you know, sexy title.
It's also like, you know, I, I know there was like a NASCAR thunder game on like either
Xbox or dreamcast or something.
I just don't watch enough NASCAR to know.
Yeah. It's like, you say that instead of like vroom vroom.
Right now NASCAR F1, like all that stuff.
Like I want to know, I want to know all about the indie series.
Like I want to watch that stuff because they all cut great promos and have great like TV
specials. But when you watch the actual races, it doesn't, it doesn't ever quite get there.
It's kind of, it kind of feels like it's like, oh, well that's just like, that's just
who had the best car that day.
And they started in the pole position and they finished in the pole position or like, you
know, they were in second and they finished in the pole position.
Big fucking deal. Right.
It's like, it's like, it just kind of feels like a foregone conclusion when she watched
it where it's like, oh, I don't know what I was expecting.
I guess I was expecting crashes.
Right. Like that's the other reason to watch all this stuff is like, let's see somebody die.
Right. Like that's another part of this whole thing that nobody wants to unpack, but it is another
reason why people watch this sport days of thunder.
The video game that we are playing today goes out of its way to separate itself from
the movie. Agree.
Disagree. I, I, I wouldn't know.
I can't, I can't really have an opinion on it cause I haven't seen the movie and Sean
you haven't either. Like you never, you didn't pick up any plot beats, right?
You weren't like, oh yeah.
Right. figured out my name is trickle well and sometimes i have i have bad luck or rough luck or what do
they say i think it's funny that like we're basing what a movie game should be by like how
the uh the back to the future games did it of like trying to just like oh this scene and that scene
right um and i i guess we didn't we didn't really get a lot of like just not when we think of movie
tie-in games we think of like the kind of hero action tie-in games and not a racing game so what
they're actually doing here is just like this is a nascar game and it really doesn't have anything
much to do with the movie itself except the fact that you are that racer i don't know it's yeah i
mean days of thunder has the benefit of the movie has the benefit of having like its story but also
revolving around this sport and then you can take the sport and that's perfect for gameplay
whereas back to the future it's like well yeah they just do a bunch of different things in that
and you got to translate all of that into gameplay or else it's not going to seem like back to the
future or you know it'd be like if they made a mighty ducks video game you're probably just gonna
be well i mean it would be cool to do other stuff in that kind of thing too but like you could make a
mighty ducks video game where you're just playing hockey you know and it's it has something in it
that can be very easily gamified that people we know people want to play already so you don't need
to yeah go to the hospital or whatever happens in the movie yeah the best you get at like understanding
the movie or at least like you know building upon it is in the manual um because it's again another one
of those very like lengthy text heavy manuals but also doing some like world building not just like
tutorials and shit it's like you know i don't even know who it's pretending to be it it starts off with
the overview let me drive you build me a car and i'll win daytona next year that's not like in quotes
or anything that's just that's just text and then the next paragraph is think so huh you're raw
untested it's like this is a conversation like this is the overview like it's a little confusing
what's going on but um as as joe mentioned yes you're cole trickle rookie driver and you are uh going
to try and win uh the daytona 500 yeah to do so you have to go uh you know kind of like through various
races in nascar and that is like where that's the best part to pick up into the actual discussion of
the video game in this episode uh because the very first uh level of the game you're at daytona beach
and uh you will immediately be thrown into it with a uh uh what like a lap what's a qualifying lap
qualifying lap so that's like you know hey now go drive here's the keys go drive so how's driving
it's it's it's it's pretty sim i guess like i feel like it's a very it's super simplified um maybe too
simplified in in so much that like it's not a typical racer we have played racers like this before
where you aren't holding down an accelerator you are holding down an accelerator to then set the point
at which you want to go that fast um and then you can just let go of the controller and it'll just
stick at that that speed so it does not feel like the i have played nascar games before and most racing
games feel this way too it doesn't feel like that yeah it doesn't feel like you're putting the pedal
to the metal it doesn't it doesn't feel like you're pushing the car forward just by like i don't know
there's like this there's this feeling of when you're holding like the a button and that is the
accelerator and like when you let go you decelerate that like it that makes it feel like you're driving i
don't know yeah i think that this was maybe we've seen something like this before but have we ever seen
something where you hold until the point that you want to be accelerating at but then pressing the
decelerate just like is like turns it completely off you know like then like that's what's weird
to me i would like if you're gonna have it like hold a to to kind of like accelerate until you want
to stop and stay at that speed then it should be like hold b to decelerate and stop and stay at that
speed but instead it's like press b once in like it's like you turned off cruise control and you're
gonna now coast and then you have to press it again to set it again no it's like you pulled the
keys out of the car yeah yeah right and then and then all that to say is like all what that really
translates to is when you're taking a taking a turn which is every every one and a half seconds of this
game when you're taking a turn you have to slow down but then it's like this weird combination of
button inputs where you like you have to hit b to slow down they have to watch it slow down and then
press a again real quick when you want to stay at that speed or else you're gonna lose a ton of speed
yeah so that that took took a while for my brain to to readjust to it's weird that this whole thing
has happened at least twice where a car has worked like this when if you think about a car and you
think about a gas pedal and a brake pedal and you think like oh there's an a button and a b button like
this is one of the what this is why there's so many racing games like it's it's pretty easy to
transpose this onto a controller and yet we've got this weird way that a car doesn't work yeah
as the controls um that said like you know once you get used to that like you you're typical like if
you play a lot of racers you then end up trying to do like apex turns and like decelerating into a
turn and trying to accelerate out of a turn but the problem there is that like once you start
decelerating it's like you can't just feather it like you you immediately lose like 50 miles an hour
yeah tap it and so there's not really that smooth transition that always feels good when you actually
hit something like that in gran turismo or some other game uh it feels kind of jank at that point
yeah and speaking of losing like 50 miles per hour all at once i think this kid this was more
of a factor when you had other racers on the road but right away in this preliminary round like
it was weird because like it takes a while for the visual feedback of what your car is doing to catch
up to that so it's like yeah i see i just lost 100 miles per hour but does not look like i'm going any
slower on the car screen so like that makes it a little a little weird too that could just be the
turns though too right because you're only decelerating on the turn so it could just be
that now like it's it's wider and you're on the turn so it doesn't look like the same sense of
speed that you were getting on the straightaways yeah but even if i like bumped into somebody or
like bumped into a wall on a straightaway for some reason i don't know why that would happen but like
even if i did it on a straightaway i remember thinking like why does it say i'm going so much slower
like when i'm accelerating like i'm not noticing a ton of feedback that makes it like oh yeah now i'm
going faster than i was a minute ago sure sure and when you bump into people too it's like well
hold on a minute huge problem here no crashes the hell's going on yeah that's the whole point people
playing nascar baby like oh here's the crashes it's just like you bump into people and it's like bumper
cars it's like oop now they now they take the lead and it's like why is it that like when i bump into
them it doesn't affect them but when they bump into me it also doesn't affect them they're just really
good at bumping into me i mean if you if you block well enough like it they they end up like you're
usually bumping into the into the ass of somebody else obviously you're gonna start going slower
but you can also have them just hit your ass and then they'll kind of drag behind you that's true
that's true and everything you guys were describing about how to control this car it it all checks out
it is it is as confusing as it sounds um but like sean said it is something you kind of learn to
adapt to for this specific game it's not like all of a sudden you're gonna go play uh like an actual
sim racer and be like oh i thought i was just gonna lock in there like no you know you know it's happening
here but it kind of becomes because the tracks are small too becomes almost rhythmic of like you know
those those extreme drops from when when you uh press the b button to uh you know break it you you
start to you know learn that it's like it's a very quick tap and then you're right back into
accelerate mode and like you learn the turns am i wrong in thinking that like the way to do the turn
is to start on the inside and drift out to the outside not hug the inside the entire time
yeah because i tried hugging the inside the entire time and that just actually winds up
making you lose a lot of speed to be going slow enough in fact what it should be if this game had a
wasn't just like faking 3d which it actually does look pretty good just to throw that in there um
would you would want to start on the on the exterior of the track then at the you know at the middle of
the turn sort of try and kiss the left side and then as you're accelerating allow yourself to drift
to the right as well anybody that plays racing games like kind of has that in their head as how
you should try and take a turn at least at the most like basic level um but you can start on the interior
and allow yourself to drift to the right because it's not really it's it's not really simulating
anything there and other than managing your speed and uh the apex of the turns and everything you
also have to manage your fuel uh there's a big fuel um uh gauge in the uh top left corner and when that
is coming close to running out obviously you'll have to pit stop to pit stop uh there isn't like an
actual lane you have to enter you'll just see uh the words pit stop written uh along the side of the track
usually near the um the checkered uh starting and finishing point uh so you just kind of hug that
and then you enter the pit stop and then you welcome to a whole nother game baby welcome to a whole
different game i thought i was playing uh you know nascar checkers but i was playing nascar chess
yeah my just before we get into like the actual mechanics of the actual pit my favorite thing about
this is that if you try and go fast and you don't slow down enough as you're entering the pit you
will just blow right through it and have to go back around yeah it'll like actually give you the
little cut scene of you entering the pit and you just keep going you just fly through the little cut
scene but then you get in there and now you are all of your pit crew and i hope there's some time
dilation going on here because it's gonna take you a while to do everything you need to do
yeah and i know that how a pit crew works yeah i was gonna say i know pit crews like nowadays are like
really like like a second or so maybe even like a second is too much at this point but like
obviously like in the 90s it wasn't that fast but it also wasn't like i don't know i was clocking in
like 40 seconds or something like yeah it's like it doesn't take 40 seconds either but joe i think
you know i'm not gonna scoop your story but like i think you were about to say this isn't how pit
crews work you're right but but why go go for it well because you have to you have to select each
member of the pit crew and do their task individually it is so you have to yeah you can't all they can't
all be doing it at the same time so you just have to like it's it's it's weird the first time you do
it i i will say the first time i did it i was clocking like two minutes and 30 seconds because i was
like what is going on here so you can still you can almost get it to look like they're all doing
it at once because once you select like let's say you've got the guy at the jack and then you
raise the jack up now you can quickly select both of the wheel guys and their animation keeps playing
even if you switch to another uh oh see i didn't realize i guess yeah you don't have to wait for like
the tire change to to finish uh to start another task so you can get a few going at once but then
you have to like walk all the way around because the guy with the wrench who works on the engine
for some reason can't man the jack on the other side so in order to get the other wheels up you gotta
walk all the way around get the other jack going and then also for some reason the guy with the fuel
can't be uh it can't be fueling while the jack is up so i guess you would want to work on the engine
and gas up at the same time i i don't know but there's a lot going on to joe's point though it's
like i agree with you that like you know at least you can you can get them started but like that's not
how a pit crew does everything all at once no absolutely yeah so it's like why is it why isn't it
just like you don't know who you're gonna be on the crew this time right and it's like all of a sudden
you have to like do that job and then everybody else is working too like i don't know that doesn't
sound great either so i'm just throwing that out there on the fly but like there has to be a better
way to do this i like that they made it interactive like that is that if that was unexpected i wasn't
actually even doing anything the first time i entered the pit i just sat there and i was like oh oh this
is me yeah maybe like they could abstract it a bit more and like make it just like a quick time
event but that doesn't exist yet so yeah like if you had to get like a couple things in the middle of
like a uh of like a like a bar with a hot zone or something but i don't know it's weird that it that
that you do it this way but i think that's part probably one of the draws to make it more authentic
yeah i i like the idea of it and i and i think i would like the idea of it more if if you really
had like more of like uh oh you're you're getting new cars as you go and you're you know you understand
it your your specific car more outside of just the pit but i i like the idea it's just hard for me to
come up with a good alternative on the nes that's still fun you know it's i'm sure there's a way to do
it but like i don't think this was it but i also don't think i have a great alternative myself i
think it could have just been though like where the the individual crew members still like do their
thing but then like you know i'm not saying quick time events but like all of a sudden you know the
guy goes and he uh has the jack and you have to hit control pad up a few times right and then like
another guy comes and it's with the wrench and it's like hit the aaa you know and it's like
maybe that's like enough whereas like you're not trying to like move all these parts at once but
you're just being the the active role as they're doing it this way it's like you're just clicking
like the up button three times the a button three times like as as these things roll through because
this isn't this isn't that kind of game like this doesn't have to be intense and it isn't intense for
what it's worth but like you want to get back i mean it's kind of intense because you over time you're
you also get like that little uh boop every time you're passed and you want to get this done fast
enough so you don't get that many boops that's why i do think there there is some time dilation going
on here because it takes it takes more time to do this than it does for you to do a full lap so uh
but then they should just time dilate the the clock too right like they should just make it this way
you you know what your your actual time is compared you know it's weird that it has this other
i'm not against that um i meant it's not that intense as in like it's not the world's hardest
thing to do it's just it's just that unfortunately it takes a lot of time and it takes you out of the
race that you're like you're building a rhythm for you know like it's not that easy to pass people in
this kind of thing either you know it's to make up ground and everything uh especially after you lose
those places in the um pit it's not like oh well i'll just get them right back when i start driving
again it's not like the ai is stupid i mean yeah so i know that we're being we've been a little crass
and talked about just turning left and like where the crash is but i think that the like when and how
to pit is one of the and this is just me guessing is probably one of the pillars of strategy in nascar
uh so i i i appreciate that something that is important to the sport is is more than just a
you gotta do this every 10 to 15 laps and it's just gonna like you automatically lose x amount of
time there's no way for you to be better at this um so i i i appreciate that it's there in the form
that it's in it's just it is goofy yeah i wonder i wonder how much of like our experience with it is
that we're we're one we're amateurs at this this video game but as an amateur of this video game
i do feel like when i go into the the pit like i get that this is something that all racers are dealing
with yes i'm gonna lose time but so is everybody else and yeah you gotta strategize about like when
and how to do that but i do feel like the computer is just so much better at it than me and better
at like keeping its place that i feel like it's just if this was a game against other people
it would feel a little better to me what's funny too is as we watch uh as we as i watched a let's
play while we're talking i just saw the person that recorded this do it in 20 seconds yeah
oh
Thank you.
make you like race more often like you don't do like you know 80 laps or anything like you usually
just do like five laps it's all like streamlined and it's like everything's going much faster and
it's just like did this game capture nascar a little better than like some games do now like
on a on like a not on a sim scale but just on like a strategy point of view like i think this
game is the right balance of like if you know nascar and you're good at it you'll be good at this
game and if you don't know nascar but you're willing to like you know learn the driving system
the complicated driving system that they've laid out here you can also play this game and i say play
this game because i'll be honest like i wasn't placing first i wasn't getting anywhere but like
i was enjoying like myself racing right like like getting better at making the turns learning how the
pit crew thing worked like i can't say i'll sink like 100 hours into this game or whatever but like
it's not it's not very friendly at first and it does get friendly which means that somehow they they have
designed something right yeah i'll agree that it is more intuitive after fussing around with it for a bit
than one would think uh i i was expecting this to not really have any intensity and like the sense of
speed is definitely debatable um but it's it is i would i like your use of the word friendly there
like it's something you can get into i'm torn because i do think yeah the more i played it the more like
i got it it felt a little smoother i think the sense of speed is middle of the road from what
we've seen on the uh nes which is which is not you know not a bad thing not a good thing i just i i
don't know i mean i don't know if i needed music i needed something but i don't know there's no music
i just found these races just kind of boring like it was just i mean i didn't feel the excitement
really at any point it's a good point though joe about the about the music like maybe they were
trying to make it sound like the roar of the car but they can't do that on the nes yeah and hey i
was impressed with that sound effect at first and i was like oh yeah it does sound like a car and i was
like all right turn it off maybe if there was just like smaller gaps between the checkerboard pattern
that they got to even have there be any sense of speed like maybe if that was a little faster
this would feel more intense but um yeah i i get it and then you know not not to like again i feel
like i've often lately i'm just like really uh scooping my own essential games let's vote but like
the when i'm on like the second race and it's like and this race is 35 laps i'm like i'm like
i cringe at that idea i'm just like that's not a good sign for me well that's actually a an order
of magnitude fewer than there would be in a real race oh i know yeah but like still it's still much
more than we've seen in most uh nes races and it's not particularly uh other than from like a
there isn't a story but like from a progression point of view there isn't any like reward for
moving on to the next race you know like it's not you don't like get a a power up or or a
faster car it's just like okay cool you did that now do this it's like oh that's it's not very
friendly you know like that to to the opposite of what i was saying earlier it's like okay like new
track so new something new to learn and everything maybe if you win or at least place in the race
like nicole kidman comes up and like gives you a hug or something like that would be pretty cool
oh hell yeah or she tells you how great it is to be at the movies
what else do i have here um no because this is all well yeah i guess i should mention that even
though i said that it wasn't tied to the movie i meant by the video game standards at least tom
cruise is on the box art of the game as well which would be confusing because you might think oh he'll be
in the game as well but you'll never see like a detail he's in the car yeah he's in the car take
our word for it and that's tom cruise he drives the car days of thunder 2 the movie is actually coming
out why now they're just following well top gun 2 yeah yeah well apparently there's also another
the top gun 3 is happening as well i don't know if i'm gonna get like in trouble for saying that um
what do you mean no you know like it because i haven't seen like a trailer for it or anything
but like you just know because you're an insider yeah i'm an insider right well nda is you know yeah
i'm not in i'm not on any nda's so should be good there uh but days of thunder 2 apparently
no nicole kidman that's unfortunate margot robbie wow they have okay is tom cruise in it tom cruise is in
it tom cruise was like i'll do it yeah he's like i'll do it but i don't want i don't want to go i
don't want anybody my age to be sharing scenes with me and it should be mentioned that that is um
tom's car from the movie uh in the game as well that green and yellow car he did drive that uh you
know one thing i gotta talk about with the movie and i'm sorry if it sounds like now i don't want to
talk about the game but like the movie has this one scene where uh you watched the movie i did yeah
okay tom cruise's um arch rival uh whose name escapes me right now because it's been a while
ricky bobby no stop it he he like does a move in the during the during one of the races to screw
tom cruise over and and it's like you know hey that was pretty dirty play but it wasn't like
wasn't like he like slashed his tires or anything you know what i mean it was just like the creative
way to like screw you over and like you know the nascar gods wouldn't be happy about it i'm sure
there'll be an article you know in the uh you know in the nascar times about it and people will read
about it and steven a smith will have a hot take about it but like it wasn't that controversial you know
like it's just gonna be something people talk about he takes the checkered flag and does his
victory lap tom cruise gets back in the car that is now like you know pretty beat this shit gets back
in the car and just drives at the guy and fucking like you know uh tries to kill him yeah like yeah
you like no he's like he t-bones him and it's just like wait a minute like you would be immediately
you're the bad guy but you would be like immediately banned from nascar yeah probably on trial for doing
something like that you know what i mean like it was just kind of like rubbed off like i'm you know
it wasn't brushed aside but it was it was kind of weird that it's like that's not like the end of the
movie yeah i don't know i wonder maybe that maybe does that happen i don't know i haven't really
watched much it's like charging the plate or charging the mound rather yeah i know that during f1 races
because they occasionally will like um have their have their team radios come up like they will
play dirty during the race to like purposely box out specific people or yeah but this is post race
right this is that's what i'm saying this has never happened post race this is nobody's ever been t-boned
after a race or even just like taking a shot at somebody right like what the hell is going on here
like he was actually driving home after the race he was like pulling into his driveway and then tom
cruise t-boned him from the yard yeah tom cruise it would have been better if he just like drove all
over his lawn right like that would have made more sense it's like oh he's angry and i'm angry about
that scene i'm so fired up that i think we should do the essential games list
days of thunder is a movie i would recommend actually yeah you guys should watch it um but
you have to watch it on like a huge screen like honestly i know back in the day they had a vhs and
a 32 inch crt but i think this thing requires 77 inches or more and i don't know if it's just because
some of us don't have that much wall mike that's what i was gonna say though 77 inches or more it
sounds like i'm uh i'm at the caveman olympics again i'm fucking horny right it's like let's go
you were the only one thinking that uh okay yeah probably true i gotta get uh offline i am so online
right now uh back to the review of the game itself nah nah uh it's not even the best driving game we've
played on the nes so it's not gonna get it for that i wish that the pit stop thing was fun though
i gotta say i wish it was actually fun because when i realized it was like oh that's me that's my turn
like i was like hell yeah and then i realized i don't even really know what i would be doing so then
i went to the manual i was like okay i get it now and it wasn't fun it should be like should be fun
to work on cars right like they they kind of screwed that up a little bit but maybe it's because
you also like have to pit like more than once a race like maybe you shouldn't do that like maybe
i'm just bad at my fuel or whatever but like make that make that like more rare don't make that like
part of it because the the game is sold because we're racing and i want to make sure that like the
racing is the best it can be and it's not so it's not on the essential games list joe yeah just to add to
your your pit stop suggestions there too like i i wonder and i don't know i i'm assuming this is
accurate to to real nascar but like yeah what if you had to do something that is actually different
based on the condition of your car like you know i know that like i i don't know i know that you can
go in there with like not all of your tires are screwed up but like you have to just do all
everything right before you know you don't you can you don't you can just fuel up if you want
no i didn't even realize that but like but still i wish that there was like oh now i have to do i
don't know how many other things there are to do other than change tires fuel up but like oh because
of this one thing i got you know something that like connects you to the car a little more i i think i
would appreciate more but again maybe i don't know how that would work but just a thought but the pit
stop aside i think i think i just don't get this game i i don't know i i don't really have
much fun with any of it i'm not like saying it's a train wreck i just i don't know that even the
actual racing is just very dull to me so this this is definitely not my cup of tea um and i'm
certainly not going to vote it essential sean yeah i mean i i think that there's i was charmed by this
game uh just from the things that they do simulate and the the visuals look good and like one thing
that i didn't really mention is that like you can actually like you can actually keep track of the
other racers kind of like it seems like in in a lot of racing games that we've played it's just like
oh you're gonna run into this every two seconds you're gonna have to have you're gonna have to pass
somebody but even if you like sort of look ahead on a turn like you can see like that guy is that far
ahead of you and just that idea of persistence i appreciate um i i'd say that the like the actual
feel of racing is a little wonky just because of the way that the gas pedal works i don't think there
was any real way that they were gonna get past that for me um but what they did do i think they
did well it's just yeah it's just it feels weird um not the best racing game we've played uh but this
is way better than i thought i was gonna be uh but still not essential listing off some of the other
racing games we've played and i'm gonna be a little liberal here with what a racing game is but um we
have excite bike so let's start there uh would you put days of thunder above or below excite bike
below i would put i don't even really like excite bike that much i would put this below excite bike
uh rad rad racer gotta gotta look it up real quick no no you don't come on rad racer yes i i gotta
look it up but yeah this also below rad racer okay cool yeah we're not we're not doing the whole thing
we're not we're not comparing rad racer yeah right now just saying you're gonna go through all of
them yeah yeah rc pro am oh we can't we can't put go through all these what do you mean we got we got
six more how much longer would it take rc pro am i think it's a no doubt that uh rc prime is better
than days of thunder yeah i actually quite liked rc pro am cobra triangle i'd say below that's the water
one right yeah cobra triangle was fun yeah that was kind of i did not say that this was
a great game wait a minute this isn't an attack on you i just was curious i was just curious where
this would fall in the racing catalog i was wondering why you weren't answering al answer
jr's turbo racing worse than this i gotta i gotta look it up i remember the name i can't i i don't
really remember did i experience with this well then you're gonna be over honestly probably still
below just by looking at it but i i don't know al answer juniors was hard that's like that's the
difference at least i felt like i could drive these these these laps yeah i don't know if i could
actually do a lot of what al answer juniors turbo racing wanted me to do uh so i will agree with sean
and so we have figured it out where where it's going but just just to list off the other two
there's rad racer 2 which is actually worse than rad racer 1 so yeah i'm not yeah i'm not sure
maybe i'd put days of thunder over rad racer 2 maybe it'd be like middle maybe it'd be like equal
to each other yeah i think i might put it over to i remember rad racer 2 being also very bland and
then there's the final one bigfoot i think i think days of thunder is better than bigfoot
i agree i also think that rad racer 2 is the other game that accelerated in the same way
if i'm not mistaken oh interesting yeah you might you might be right i'll put um i'll put this game
above bigfoot only because i remember on the bigfoot episode you invited sean to a monster truck rally
didn't invite me that's true we didn't go it means unapologetically my offer still stands sean
whenever you want but actually watching uh watching this footage of bigfoot yeah i i think i actually
would put it um below this game here's a question i should have asked on the main show does does days
of thunder's pit stop have any like relationship to top gun the video games carrier landing sequence
like is there like a shared point of frustration there for both games is it the same developer
no but it's the same it's a tom cruise movie
um i mean i don't remember being i remember being much more frustrated with the landing
than i was with the pit stop although i don't like the pit stop either
but yeah it is weird that they both have this all right well okie dokie
ethi
ethi!